donnez de water-polo gants palmes tuba
et surtout pas les cross
rien qu'à l'équipement on comprend que
le hockey subaquatique mêle plusieurs
disciplines
c'est un sport avant trois dimensions
c'est à dire que quand on est sous l'eau
les adversaires ils peuvent arriver de
droite de gauche derrière le devant mais
aussi de la surface dans d'autres su
donc ça prend vraiment en comptait trois
dimensions ce sport collectif trouve ses
origines dans les pays anglo saxons
enchaîné les hockeyeurs s'entraîne deux
fois par semaine deux équipes de ch'ti
joueurs s'affrontent dans l'eau en deux
mi temps de 15 minutes
le but du jeu est de pousser le palet au
fond de l'eau jusqu'à une rigole en fer
qui représente les buts et c'est à peu
près les mêmes règles que le hockey sur
glace et le c'est un sport qui
s'apparente aussi beaucoup au rugby
sport de contact le hockey subaquatique
a vu sa technique progresser au début
des années 90 c'est un sport je trouve
hyper complémentaires on fait du sport
on fait de l'apnée
enfin c'est physique et aussi ont ils
fait une esprit d'entre elles parce qu
on est en équipe et du coup c'était un
peu tous ses à côtés qui me plaisait
bien
on est sous l'eau donc on va pas
communiquer beaucoup on va dire pendant
le match
après on a quand même des périodes de à
la surface qu'on espérait de communiquer
on a des temps morts en match donc on va
pouvoir communiquer après ça va être la
force de jouer avec notre équipe on va
savoir comment se placer avec les gens
comment joue certaines personnes et
après ça va être le jeu des équipes qui
va être primordiale apparu pour la
première fois dans l'hexagone à
montauban en 1968 la discipline connaît
ses premiers championnats du monde en
1980 nation majeure de la discipline la
france a obtenu le titre à trois
reprises en 1988 en 2008 et en 2013